I wanted to
um just to speak to the uh just the
incredible endurance of your uh of your
fan base and how loyal they are and how
it just uh has it it grew and grew and
grew and then they've always been with
you and they've followed you the the
whole way I mean your your the shows the
number of people that you play to you
played one show in Rush at a 1.6 million
people
um I believe it was a free show and I
think that was a mistake
I
don't know if the money at that time was
worth anything
but uh it was right in the wake of the
perestroika yeah transitional thing I
mean it was so it was negotiated between
I think it was a Gorbachev maybe Yeltsin
was coming into power at the time and it
was negotiated between the students and
the people running the uprisings and the
demonstrations and the government in
that period of transition that part of
what they wanted the students wanted was
a rock and roll show and so AC DC and
Metallica were on tour uh in Western
Europe that whole summer and two three
weeks before the end of the tour they
want you to come to Russia and plan at
that time I mean this is just a couple
years after Reagan uh you know Bush
senior was president and it was still
you know the evil Russians and and all
of that stuff and they're gonna you know
drop nuclear bombs on you next week and
and I mean there was all that that crazy
stuff so going to Russia
was like holy but here we are here
we are on the Red Square here we are
running around seeing you know the
sights and the Kremlin and and then we
were there for maybe three days and then
played that insane show uh we weren't
really prepared for what that was going
to be but we had the camera crew led by
Wayne Isham and and his cohorts and they
filmed it and if you go to YouTube now
it is among the most
surreal and extraordinary footage of
Metallica ever because like you're
saying it is Metallica and whether it's
a million people a million and a half
who knows what the real number is but
there are tens of thousands of Russian
soldiers in uniform that are supposed to
be protecting the audience and there as
into the show and rocking along as all
the kids are there are Sikorsky
helicopters flying right over the
audience I don't know if it's a scarecot
tactic or where they're keeping people
whatever it is but these giant Sikorsky
helicopters hovering right over the
audience looked like people could just
Reach Out And Touch them and it is
um it's a real mind of a concert to
watch I guess 30 years later so if
anybody out there listening check it out
on YouTube
to me it's the power of
um and I'm going to want to talk about
how I love the your origin story is so
amazing and your fans all know it but I
want to make sure my fans know your
origin story because it is absolutely
incredible but to think that it started
out
two guys fighting each other
um you know putting ads in the paper
recycler yeah
and and then what happens is you end up
getting uh you can unify all these
people uh in in Russia at a very
delicate time I mean we could really use
that today obviously but getting 1.6
million people to come to a concert and
I think a lot of them were chaining
around they know the lyrics they know
the words they know the syncopation of
all the songs and it's because it was
all from bootleg tapes because there was
no record industry in the Eastern Europe
at the time but the unifying power of
that the unifying power of uh you know
any kind of art form but especially uh
the music of Metallica just worldwide is
a very positive thing yeah you know it's
pretty critical I'll tell you another
version of that that comes to mind uh
first is uh we've played down in Abu
Dhabi and Dubai a couple two three times
and um great great place to come and
play primarily because
the fans come in from Iran they come in
from Iraq they come in from Saudi they
come in from Kuwait they come in from
Lebanon they come in from Bahrain they
come in from Syria they come in from all
over the Middle East and you're playing
to 30 40 000 kids we've done it two or
three times and they all bring their
Flags their national flags and the
Iranians and the Iraqis and the Saudis
and everybody else are sharing an
experience together right and in that
Arena
they all are completely United around
the music and and and kind of there's a
brotherly feeling of all of us in this
together including the band members and
then outside of that Arena I don't need
to
to tell you guys you know these
countries not only don't like each other
but hate each other and fight Wars over
religion and territory on the rest of it
so
it does speak to to the power of music
uh and and and what the possibilities
are in a lot of of places in the world
uh you know we've played in India we've
played in you know places like Indonesia
Malaysia Antarctica didn't you we we
played Antarctica yes we were there was
uh and it was it was it was by chance it
it was not something that we sat down
well in you know two years from now
let's check all the seven continent
boxes it wasn't like that we were
playing somewhere we're playing
somewhere else we're playing and then we
were five or six into it and somebody
said well hang on a second if we're
gonna do this then let's do it and we
got an offer uh from um
I think it was Coca-Cola uh they were
doing a contest for Latin America and
they invited us to come down and play
for contest winners on a Chilean
research base in Antarctica and so we
flew down and we're on a
talk about different bring different
nationalities together we were on a
Russian Icebreaker on a Chilean anchored
off a Chilean research base playing to
Argentina Argentinian Chilean and
Brazilian Coca-Cola contest winners in a
space that was maybe twice of the room
we're in right and there was a small
room yeah it was uh it was a tent that
was set up and on top of that uh
everybody in the audience had headphones
on like we all do now because it was
silent disco style because uh part of
the part of the part of part of the deal
was we couldn't disturb the environment
and the Penguins and and all the
incredible Wildlife down there so the
only thing you could hear in that tent
uh where the drums or the acoustic drums
and James's vocals but all the
amplifiers everything that was Amplified
the guitar is the bass Etc were all
going through these uh sort of boxes
into everybody's headphones so you put
all those elements together and that was
one of the most unique three or four
days ever and on top of it the band
members and all our wonderful crew and
all the contest winners were staying on
that Icebreaker together so it was a
real communal experience and and we all
had our meals together and if anybody
wanted a beverage or post your drink or
whatever we go down the bar right and it
was the 200 contest winner it was one of
the best uh trips we've ever had like
one guy asked for a Pepsi exactly